[Music]
who would you save the pedestrian in the
road all the drivers in the car it's not
easy and yet that's the kinda decision
which millions autonomous cars would
have to make in the near future we
program the machine but who do we tell
it to save that is the set up of the
moral machine experiment there are so
many moral decisions that we usually
make during the day we don't realize in
driverless cars these decisions will
have to be implemented ahead of time the
goal was to open this discussion to the
public some decisions might seem simple
should the car save a family of four or
a cat but what about a homeless person
in their dog instead of a businessman or
how about two athletes and an old woman
instead of two school children the
problem was that there were so many
combination so many so many possible
accidents that it seemed impossible to
investigate them all using plastic
social science methods not only that
bounder people's culture and background
affect the decisions that they make the
only option we had really was to turn it
into viral website of course it's easier
said than done right but that is exactly
what the team managed to do they turned
these situations into an online task
that people across the globe wanted to
share and take part in they gathered
almost 40 million moral decisions taken
from millions of online participants
across 233 countries and territories
from all around the world the results
are intriguing first there are three
fundamental principles which hold true
across the world the main results of the
paper for me are first the big three in
people's preferences which is save human
save the greater number save the kids
and the second most interesting finding
was the clusters the clusters of
countries with different moral profiles
the first cluster
included many Western countries the
second cluster had many Eastern
countries and the third cluster had
countries from Latin America and also
from former French colonies the cultural
difference we find are sometimes hard to
describe because they're
multi-dimensional but some of them are
very striking like the fact that Eastern
countries do not have such a strong
preference for saving young lives
Eastern countries seem to be more
respectful of older people which I
thought was a very interesting finding
and it wasn't just age one cluster
showed an unexpectedly strong preference
for saving women over men I was also
struck by the fact that French and the
certain French sub cluster was so
interested in saving women that was yeah
I'm still not quite sure what's going on
here
another surprising finding concerned
people's social status on one side we
put male and female executives and other
side we put a homeless person the higher
the economic inequality in a country the
more people were willing to spare the
executives at the cost of the homeless
people this work provides new insight
into how morals change across cultures
and the team see particular relevance to
the field of artificial intelligence and
autonomous vehicles in the grand scheme
of it
I think these results are going to be
very important to line or to feel
artificial intelligent to human values
we sometimes change our mind other
people next to us don't think the same
thing we do other countries don't think
the same things we do so aligning AI and
human role value is only possible if we
do understand these differences and
that's what we try to do I so much hope
that we can converge that we avoid a
future where you have to learn about the
new ethical setting of your car every
time you cross
some border